the left has to find somebody to blame
for Hurricane Harvey Joel Osteen gets
himself in trouble in Houston plus we'll
talk about the latest from Berkeley and
yes there are our developments I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show so
you may not know the difference at all
but it is 1000° in this studio our air
conditioning is broken today so if you
see me it looks like I'm sweating
copiously or if it doesn't look like I'm
sweating it all because I'm made of ice
and steel it's all the same it's very
warm in the studio nonetheless we will
soldier through because that's the kind
of people we are it's just like Normandy
because I'm the left everything is like
Normandy so in any case we'll talk about
everything having to do with Joel Osteen
whether or not he actually barred people
from his giant Lakewood Church in
Houston there's been a lot of talk
online about that we also talked about
the left obvious and deep desire to peg
hurricane Harvey on someone and
something beyond whether we'll talk
about all that stuff but first I want to
say thanks to our sponsors are over at
Boleyn branch so when it comes to sleep
as I have said many times on the program
I stink at it I'm good at a great many
things not including dancing but another
thing I'm bad at is sleep sleep is not
my thing but thanks to Bolin branch my
sleep quality has gotten significantly
better Boleyn branch makes the best
sheets there are there are five stages
of sleep and all of them can be better
with these sheets the fact is they are
100% organic cotton they breathe better
don't worry about the thread count on
your sheets this is what I've learned
from Poland branch you go to the grocery
store and and outside in the parking lot
there's some skeezy guy who's selling
future like oh it's a thousand thread
count I'm sure it's great no it turns
out it's made of plastic and it's a tarp
well you need is the organic cotton
sheets over at bowl and branch comm they
don't make you pay the expensive retail
price so you're paying about half the
price you would for twice the quality of
these kinds of sheets you can try them
for 30 nights if you don't like them you
can send them right back for a full
refund if you don't like them and I
promise you you will like them everyone
who sleeps on pole and branch sheets
that I've talked to really really enjoys
them the only sheets that we allow in
our house are bowline branch bought them
for my kids bought them for myself they
are really terrific go to bull and
branch calm today you get $50 off your
first set of sheets plus free shipping
when he use the promo code ban again
that's bull and branch calm Bo LL and
branch calm and use that promo club and
get 50 bucks off your first set of
sheets plus
free shipping 3x presidents and Bill
Clinton's lovers presumably sleep on
ball and branch sheets they are highly
recommended bolt and branch comm use
that promo code Ben best sheets in
America they're really terrific okay so
the big controversy that has lit the
internet aflame is is happening over
Joel Osteen's church Lakewood Church so
for those who don't know Joel Osteen
Joel Osteen is a preacher of what they
call prosperity gospel prosperity gospel
is basically the notion that if you
follow God's rules and give lots of
charity that God will be nice to you and
make you rich this is the goddess
gumball machine view of life I am NOT a
fan there are people in the Jewish
community could do something similar
they do this routine where it's like
well if you give a lot of charity then
you will surely prosper and you will do
better in life and there will be
material benefits there's certain
behavior I think that you follow secular
or religious and you're more likely to
prosper like don't have kids until
you're married finish high school make
good decisions with your money
don't blow it on booze and strippers or
I mean these are obvious things that if
you follow God's plan or basic human
morality you're more likely to be
prosperous but that's not really the
baseline of prosperity gospel
prosperity gospel says God wants you to
be wealthy God wants you to be rich and
therefore if you pray hard enough and
give enough charity and you act any in a
gospel forward manner then you will
inevitably become wealthy or rich
because God wants you to be rich Joel
Osteen Osteen has made a fortune off of
this he lives in a 10.5 million dollar
home in Texas he also has a show a
televangelism show that's watched by
some 42 million people a week I guess
that's in just enormous Lakewood Church
was in old Houston Rockets arena I
believe made over for his church it
holds 17,000 people and it is packed
every Sunday so with all of this going
on with Joel Osteen with his belief
system there's no question that a lot of
people are looking for reason to jump on
him so the reason came yesterday when it
came out online that Joel Osteen had
said we are shutting down services for
Saturday and Sunday over at the church
and we're basically closing the premises
and a lot of people said well hold on
why aren't you using this as a shelter
why aren't using this as a place where
people can go and sleep you know bluff
some air mattresses hand out some food
your church do some church things and
the social media people started to go
not so the the church itself said we are
flooded ray I mean the
parts of the premises are flooded this
is not a good place to go and we're
coordinating with the city and then
people started tweeting out photos of
what things look like over by Lakewood
Church like right now and it looks nice
and dry over there by August 27th August
28th here is a picture and what it
looked over by Lakewood Church a lot of
people were blasting Osteen over all of
this but then Osteen's Church released
some photos of parts of the premises and
what they look like and you can see that
some parts of the premises are flooded
right that you can see here this thing
looks like is about under two feet of
water this pillar over here and that's
and here is under ground looks like
there's about six inches of water in the
parking lot so clearly they're not
getting off scot-free but everybody is
eager to jump on Osteen so critics of
Osteen are eager to jump on him because
they think that his preaching of the
gospel is materialistic and non
spiritual and a lot of people on the
Left are eager to jump on any pastor
whatsoever so I think that before people
on the right religiously make common
cause of people on the Left who dislike
religion generally against Osteen they
should take into account what's really
going on here a lot of people on the
Left would have bashed any church any
major church that didn't open its doors
because they're looking for an
opportunity to bash religious people
that said Osteen should have known
better than all of this obviously Osteen
should have known that there are people
who are going to look at the prosperity
of his church how big it is and say he
should have been doing more throughout
all of this but it's not quite as
clear-cut as the Internet wants to make
it and that's why I wanted to sound off
on that today and sort of let you know
what the true story is that a lot of
this a lot of the criticism of Osteen
seems a little bit overblown to me now I
think you can criticize his ideology
without criticizing the without
criticizing his particular actions in
this case because I'm just not sure that
his actions in this particular case are
worthy of ire I don't have enough
information and from what I'm seeing
according to the city and according to
Osteen doesn't look like he was shutting
his doors I mean there been Prior
disasters I think during Hurricane Rita
he opened his doors to two people who
are looking for shelter they've now
opened their doors they've got the air
mattresses out there saying it has
nothing to do with social media I'm sure
it does have something to do with social
media that said the ire seems to me
somewhat overblown and Osteen should
have known better because people are out
to get him and people are out to get
religious communities even ones that I
I'm not a fan of his gospel but still
religious leaders have to know that
there is a double standard when it comes
to religious leadership the things a
secular leader would do and styncat are
not gonna be taken the same way if a
religious leader does them because
they're just held to a higher standard
particular particularly people who are
already sort of they're suspected of
prospering off the Gospels okay so with
the Osteen thing out of the way I want
to talk a little bit about the left's
perspective on the hurricane itself so
the left has been jumping to conclusions
about the hurricane looking for somebody
to blame a few years back during
Hurricane Katrina I think it was Pat
Robertson who said was it actually it
was a John Hagee's it was an evangelical
pastor and he suggested that during
Hurricane Katrina the reason for
Hurricane Katrina hitting New Orleans
had to do with God being unhappy with
New Orleans there were suggestions like
this after 9/11 there are suggestions
like this turning some hurricane seasons
in the late 90s there were religious
leaders who would come out and say this
sort of stuff the Jerry Falwell I
believe said it about 9/11 they did this
idea that that God was angry and
therefore he punished particular people
with the weather icky punished
particular people with nature and people
on the religious side of the aisle and
people on the secular side of the aisle
came and said that's inappropriate
you don't know God's mind it's who are
you to say that the God is doing this
because he doesn't like what's going on
in New Orleans I mean after all
Houston seems like a relatively
conservative place and I got the
hurricane hitting this place the secular
left went nuts right the secular left
said how dare you attribute the sins of
the people attribute the Hurricanes or
the natural disasters to the sins of the
people how dare you do all those things
the truth is that the secular hard left
is just as religious as some of the
people on the on the hard right they're
just as eager to look for some cause
outside of the weather to explain what
just happened in Houston and this is a
tendency of the human mind is to jump to
a conclusion these kind of just so
stories about why things happen the way
they do sometimes you feel like you can
see God's hand in the universe and you
feel like it's relatively clear you know
the fact that that Hitler didn't move on
Dunkirk seems like a pretty clear God's
hand in history moment when it comes to
natural disasters which are happening
constantly around the world and it seems
a little bit much to me to attribute
those to God wanting to take revenge on
- killer populations but the second were
left which hates that is perfectly
willing to ascribe the hurricane to
other things so their current God is of
course global warming so there's a been
a whole spate of articles about how
global warming is what caused this
hurricane nevermind that hurricanes have
actually been down in recent years there
was a hurricane gap for a while where it
seemed like the number of hurricanes
making landfall in the United States had
dropped pretty significantly
the left said that was due to global
warming now the left is saying that the
size of this hurricane is due to global
warming well their suggestion is that
the sort of gas fuel for hurricanes is
warm water that when hurricanes are
moving over warm water then the the
water evaporates more quickly and
because it evaporates more quickly it
becomes part of the vortex and it leads
to harder longer hurricanes the ideal
would be the cold water presumably would
quash a lot of those hurricanes so
Politico has a long article today about
how global warming is to blame for all
of this there are a bunch of people on
the Left who have been tweeting out that
global warming is to blame for all of
this that it's because of all these evil
oil companies in Texas that all this is
happening
chanc Eiger who have debated obviously a
politican he tweeted out US taxpayer
should help people of Houston in light
of this tragedy but not one dime to oil
companies who helps caused it in the
first place the suggestion being that
oil companies drilling and providing a
good a service to people who need oil
they are responsible for the size and
the scope of this hurricane Politico has
a long article as I say today all about
how global warming is the problem there
article is titled Harvey is what climate
change looks like guy named Eric Holt
house wrote it he says in all of US
history there's never been a storm like
hurricane Harvey that fact is
increasingly clear even though the rains
are still falling and the water levels
in Houston are still rising but there's
an uncomfortable point that so far
everyone is skating around we knew this
would happen decades ago we knew this
would happen we didn't care now is the
time to say it as loudly as possible
Harvey is what climate change looks like
well not really not really so they say
that Houston has been sprawled out into
the swamp for decades largely unplanned
and unsewn now that pavement has been
transformed it has transformed the BIOS
into surging torrents and shunted
Harvey's floodwaters towards homes and
businesses so these all might have
seemed like a good idea at the time but
it was a bad idea what does that have to
do with global warming nothing it has to
do instead with urban
that has nothing to a global warming I'm
gonna explain why this global warming
stuff really is evidence less in just a
second even according to some of the
left favorite sources but first I want
to say thank you to our sponsors over at
the u.s. CCA so if you are ever forced
to defend yourself with a firearm forced
to defend your wife or child your family
it's a decision that you make on the
spot try to picture the instant you know
that the threat is real you're actually
gonna have to pull the trigger many of
us know that we would act we know that
what we would do but we wouldn't know
how to do it and wouldn't know what to
do in the aftermath because the police
will show up and they will ask you
questions and they may indeed arrest you
this is why you need protection from the
law even though you are acting in
accordance with the law it's self
defense insurance from the u.s. CCA they
will support you with 100% upfront
coverage for criminal defense civil
suits and bail funding they have 24/7
critical response teams so it's the
middle of night doesn't matter us CCA is
their local attorney coordination and
more visit defend my family now calm for
coverage starting at just $13 per month
we already know that if something bad
happens we're gonna have to defend our
loved ones but now we should be prepared
for the legal and financial battle that
is sure to follow go activate your
membership today at defend my family now
calm you'll also be entered to win a
brand-new gun go to defend my family now
calm so you get a chance to win a gun
they'll give you the training that you
need plus they give you the defense that
you need in case you get in legal
trouble for exercising your Second
Amendment rights
okay so the left is trying to blame
global warming for all of this as I say
political is a long article about this
they say Harvey is the third 500 year
flood to hit the Houston area in the
past three years but Harvey is in a
class by itself by the time the storm
leaves the region on Wednesday an
estimated forty to sixty inches of rain
will have fallen on parts of Houston so
much rain has already fallen that the
National Weather Service has had to add
additional colors to its maps to account
for the extreme totals they say this is
already the worst rain storm in US
history and they say the people of
Houston didn't choose this to happen to
them but what happens next is critically
important to us climate change is making
rainstorms everywhere worse but
particularly on the Gulf Coast since the
1950s Houston has seen a 167 percent
increase in the frequency of the most
intense downpours okay so the idea here
is that global warming has made the
world warmer this is what's causing this
increased intensity of storms okay there
are a few questions here one we still
don't know how much human activity
like contributed to this level of global
warming we don't even if you accept the
IPCC's kind of average temperature
increase which they say is gonna
increase about seven degrees Fahrenheit
over the next century it's still unclear
from most scientists what percentage of
that is due to human activity it's
unclear what the solution to that is and
it's unclear that you can actually
attribute individual weather events like
this to global warming itself now I'm
going to quote you the geophysical fluid
dynamics laboratory there's a government
agency at the National Oceanic and
Atmospheric Association it says quote it
is premature to conclude that human
activities and particularly greenhouse
gas emissions that cause global warming
have already had a detectable impact on
Atlantic hurricane or global tropical
cyclone activity that said human
activities may have already caused
changes that are not yet detectable due
to the small magnitude of the changes or
observational limitations and are yet
are not yet confidently modeled in other
words we don't know right we just don't
know so they said that you know there's
not enough information to know at this
point what the story is gonna be they
say anthropogenic warming by the end of
the 21st century will likely cause
tropical cyclones to have substantially
higher rainfall rates than present-day
ones with a model projecting an increase
of about 10 to 15 percent for rainfall
rates averaged within about a hundred
kilometers of the storm center how do
they estimate that they say there's
about a sixty six percent likelihood
that that is the case over the next
century but the left wants to attribute
a 100 percent likelihood now okay
there's just not the science to prove
that there just isn't the Atlantic is a
very similar piece today talking about
how climate changed intensified
hurricane Harvey but buried it's like
paragraph 21 of this piece it says all
of this said a storm like Harvey could
have happened even if there was no
climate change planning experts have
long fretted over the possibility of a
major hurricane striking houston harvey
is also a powerful hurricane forming in
one of the most hurricane friendly
regions of the world at the peak of
hurricane season storms similar to it
would form in any climate okay this is a
leftist publication the Atlantic saying
all of this they say it's unclear what
if that climate change is having on
hurricane formation across the Greater
Atlantic Ocean so the idea that this is
definitely definitely attributable to
global warming is just not backed okay
there's just it's just not supported
doesn't mean we shouldn't worry about it
doesn't mean we shouldn't do more
climate research on it but the notion
that the
is absolutely clear to anybody who
denies it as a global warming denier is
just not correct it's just not true but
the left has to attribute blame to
somebody Keith Olbermann is now
attributing blame to Betsy DeVos the
Secretary of Education this nutjob
Olbermann here's what he had to tweet he
said this hurricane is gonna do less
damage to schools than you are mother
bleep er to Betsy DeVos the Secretary of
Education all she did was sweet out our
prayers are with all those in the path
of Hurricane Harvey and he's angry at
her he's enraged at her there's a
University of Tampa professor who is
fired I don't think he should been fired
for this but he was fired for tweeting
today that the hurricane happened to
Trump supporters that they deserved that
and that hurricane and that hurricane
happened because hurricane Harvey is
attributable to two people voting for
Trump in just ridiculous ridiculous
stuff and again I think there's a
broader point to be made here which is
that the left is looking for some way to
attribute bad things that happen in the
world to the right we're constantly
looking to government as the answer to
all of our problems this demonstrates I
think the problem with thinking in these
terms generally when you look to
government is the answer to all your
problems when you think that government
is going to be God it's going to protect
you from all forms of vicissitudes when
the left has its own prosperity gospel
well if we pray to government we pay
lots of taxes it will stop hurricanes
it'll stop global warming it'll fix all
of our problems they'll prevent you from
being poor okay all of this is nonsense
even religious people who don't believe
in prosperity gospel understand that
it's not God's job to make you
prosperous it's your job to make you
prosperous and acting in accordance with
God's law maybe you'll be more
prosperous maybe you won't okay there
are no guarantees in any of this this is
what a lot of religious people believe
even those of us who are deeply
religious understand that they're as we
would say in Judaism tsadikim they're
they're righteous people who are poor
right being righteous has no guarantee
that God is going to grant you wealth in
this life it just isn't but the left is
so religion is about government that
they believe that if they just pay
homage to government if they if they
hand over all their cash if they give
government control over the economy that
somehow hurricanes like this will be
prevented major hurricanes have been
taking place on planet Earth for the
last several million years
the idea that you're going to sit around
and say the government is certainly
going to fix all of this if we just give
it enough power is really silly but you
know that's the left's worship
that's the hard left warship is trying
to blame things that happen around them
on someone or something so that they
don't have to take into account the fact
that there's some randomness to the
universe that they're simply not going
to be able to prevent it's the same
thing that Joe Biden used to say about
how we we could cure cancer if we just
got governments on the right page I'm
pretty sure that the impediment to
curing cancer is not will to care cancer
I'm fairly certain that everybody wants
to cure cancer
you know mister former vice president
but again when you worship at the altar
of government then you tend to think
that it's going to prevent all of your
problems if you just have you just hands
over all your money Katy tur sort of
evidence this Katy tur is a reporter
over at NBC News and she was asking
senator Ted Cruz about funding for
hurricane hurricane Harvey he's backed
funding for hurricane Harvey he did not
back a bill that would have that would
have funded hurricane sandy because
there was a lot of pork in it again the
premise of the question seems to be the
government can solve all the problems if
stupid Republicans would just get out of
the way
watch Cruz shellac her on this question
a lot of people are pointing out that
you voted against aid for sandy after
that catastrophic catastrophic storm up
in the Northeast that package back in
2012 and they're they're pointing at you
and saying you're asking for money now
when you weren't willing to help the
people in the Northeast what do you have
to say to them well you know look
there's time for political sniping later
I think needed funding right after that
storm I covered those people many of
them just like those in Houston lost
absolutely everything they owned
okay so again she's going after him in
these kind of blatant terms but he's
corrected the poor the hurricane sandy
bowls laden with pork when I was that
one laden with pork the reason that it
was laden with pork is because again
Democrats think the government is God
and they think that if they just donate
all their money to the government
prosperity gospel will come upon them so
for all the critiques of Joel Osteen's
perspective at least Joel's Olos teens
perspective still calls for some sort of
worship of a higher power the higher
power of the Democrats worship
apparently is the government itself okay
so I want to talk about the latest from
Berkeley and what an tifa's riot on
Sunday means for my appearance at
Berkeley in just a second but for that
I'm gonna have to go over to daily wire
calm and subscribe for $9.99 a month you
too can subscribe to daily wire comm
that gets you the rest of today's show
it gets
the rest of everydays show live it means
that when we post it later you don't
have to watch the commercials it also
means that you get Michael Moses show
live that means they get Andrew clavin's
show live so you get all of those things
plus you get the mailbag which is coming
up on Friday get to be alive
participants in the mailbag so many
questions live now answered for you live
on air which is pretty cool
so we'll do all of those things plus you
get the website ad free as well we are
not only the fastest growing podcast in
the country were the fastest growing
conservative website in the country plus
if you want the annual subscription go
over to Daley wire.com get the annual
subscription and get this the leftist
tiers hot or cold tumbler it is wondrous
in times like these when you're in an
non air-conditioned studio frying your
bleep off
now that is when you need a hot or cold
tumbler so you can sip the icy water of
the gods so make sure that you go get
that tumbler for a 99 dollar annual fee
or go over to iTunes or SoundCloud later
Spotify any of the places that post
podcasts you can get access to the bench
appear Oh show go and leave us a review
go and go and subscribe over to iTunes
it helps us with our iTunes ranking we
always appreciate it we are the largest
and fastest growing conservative podcast
in the nation
you
so a real split is now emerging with
regard to antifa on the left there are
some people in Antigua on the left who
are willing to disown Antigua it is
amazing to me by the way that ever
Republican legislature in in the country
every one of them was forced to come out
and personally denounce what happened in
Charlottesville but no Democrat
legislature I'm aware of has been forced
to denounce an Tifa no one seems to be
asking these questions I think Jake
Tapper actually has asked some people on
CNN but aside from tapper I haven't seen
anybody being asked this question
regularly do you back in Tifa should
antiva be shut down should it be
considered a criminal group should the
police be doing more to stop all of this
the police in Berkeley it's a really
crappy job on Sunday it was obvious they
did a crappy job on Sunday the
Washington Post reported that they were
supposed to block off entrances to the
park where this where this rally this
this free speech rally was taking place
instead they just allowed an tyfa to run
roughshod over them and they said well
we don't want this to become violent now
the mayor of Berkeley is calling on UC
Berkeley to cancel free speech week
itself so on Monday night Berkeley Mayor
Jesse Aaron Gwin
this is Hank barian writing for daily
wires he era Gwynn is a committed
leftist and he urged UC Berkeley to
cancel the university's plans for a free
speech week in September that happens to
coincide with speeches planned by
speakers who target the left they
arguing asserted quote I don't want
Berkeley being used as a punching bag
I'm concerned about these groups using
large protests to create mayhem it's
something we've seen in Oakland and
Berkeley free speech week is not my
speech free speech week is the is is
happening I guess about a week and a
half afterward that is going to include
provocateur is like my low it's going to
include Ann Coulter Steve Bannon is
supposed to show up for a free speech
week as well September 24th through 27th
I backed the right of all of these
people to speak no matter how much I
disagree with their opinions on things
obviously the Berkeley Patriots
spokesman Bryce Casa moto acknowledged
on Monday we're still working out the
logistics of the event with the
University and law enforcement once we
have worked out final specifics we'll be
able to confirm speakers for free speech
week I assume that that Berkeley mayor
Eric win does not want Berkeley to
approve my speech happening September
14th at the university either Berkeley
by the way still has not released
tickets I mean this is insane it's now
August 29th the speech happens in just
about two weeks they still have not
released the free tickets there are
2,000 seats
I assume that it'll sell out almost
immediately thanks to people like you if
you want to go and register
notification as soon as the tickets
become available we should pack the
house and demonstrate the free-speech
still matters you can go over to yaf dot
org for all the information there but
the fact that the Berkeley mayor is
saying openly that he doesn't want these
free speech events in his city is really
disgusting and demonstrative of the fact
that there is a rioters veto of which
leftist government officials approve and
it's not just limited to Berkeley you
remember Stephanie rawlings-blake the
baltimore mayor saying when there are
riots in Baltimore that she wanted to
give the rioters space to destroy
remember her saying that the way that
this works this sort of inside-outside
game is the of a bunch of rioters who
show up to shut down speech you don't
like and then you say oh you know what
my police just couldn't control it I
guess that we just can't have these
events anymore that's the way this works
go to hell Jesse era Glenn ok this is
still America and you don't get to deny
the First Amendment in your city just
because you're the mayor of this city
that's not the way that this works as
I've said and will continue to say no
one should show up to my speech on
September 14th looking for a fight if
you are we fully expect the police to
arrest you if they don't that's not
Jesse arrogant and it's on the and it's
on the UC Berkeley administration if the
police don't do their jobs I have
personal security for me I want all the
people who are coming to hear me speak
protected I don't want any of those
people assaulted and if they are
assaulted if the police don't do their
jobs if they're told to stand down as
apparently then we're on Sunday by the
Berkeley P by the Berkeley PD higher-ups
or by the mayor or by the Berkeley
administration and then Congress should
move fully and forthwith to withdraw
funding from UC Berkeley as well as any
federal funding connected to the City of
Berkeley overall in accordance with law
and that's something that needs to
happen as soon as possible and the left
should be calling out for this as loudly
as I am it shouldn't just be me saying
this it should be left saying this as
well first of all they've already
charged us a $15,000 fee for security
young America's Foundation said that it
would pay the fee it's a tax on free
speech the foundation for individual
rights in education regularly points out
that quote any requirement that student
organizations hosting controversial
events pay for extra security is
unconstitutional because it affects is a
price tag to events on the basis of
their expressive content and as I've
said again no one should show up ready
for violence this is the police's job
era Gwinnett has said quote I'm very
concerned about my Lea innopolis and Ann
Coulter and some of these other
right-wing speakers coming to the
Berkeley campus
because it's just a target for black
bloc to come out and commit mayhem on
the Berkeley campus and have that
potentially spill out on the street he
said I obviously believe in freedom of
speech but there's a fine line between
freedom of speech and then posing a risk
to public safety
no there is no fine line these are two
completely separate issues free speech
is my right protecting Public Safety is
your job
end of story if you're not willing to do
your job then you should be kicked out
of your office and merrily or I should
lose federal dollars for not doing your
job by the way where the hell is Jerry
Brown I live in this state I pay taxes
in the state I pay probably hundreds of
thousands of dollars in taxes in this
state the idea that that my government
the government under which I have lived
my entire life except for three years in
in Harvard I've lived my entire life in
California get that government is not
going to protect my free speech rights
or the freedom of assembly of people to
hear me or people like Milo or people
like Ann Coulter is really repulsive
really disgusting and that obviously has
nothing to do with my belief in their
message because I don't believe in the
message of some of the people that I
just mentioned
so again Berkeley just doing a horrific
job doing what it's supposed to be doing
so we'll keep you updated on all of that
meanwhile president Trump landed in
Texas just demonstrating the the ire of
the of the left when it comes to the
situation in Texas people are apparently
very very upset with milania's from she
landed and she was wearing high heels
apparently this is some sort of big deal
she was wearing stilettos I guess for
five seconds and then she changed her
shoes okay everyone was getting on her
on her back for changing her shoes it's
like a big deal like am I supposed to
think this is a big deal my wife changes
her shoes every time I go to synagogue
she wears the shoes that are comfortable
to walk in and then she changes into the
shoes that are pretty I mean I think
that women are silly for doing this but
still is this a big deal but the left
has made this a huge big deal how dare
this happened Trump is in Texas today
there are even some people at the
Washington Post saying how dare Trump
land there so let me get this straight
when George HW Bush gonna fly over
because he didn't actually want to land
and create a security problem in New
Orleans then he was a bad guy but when
Trump flies to Texas he's also a bad guy
amazing how this works so Trump you know
the truth is the Trump on hurricane on
hurricane Harvey is actually doing quite
a good job I don't see any problem
whatsoever with with what Trump has been
doing on the hurricane thus far he's
done everything that he's been asked to
do
now does that mean that some of his
other Salinas's have been obliterated no
of course Trump is still Trump this is
why his approval rating is down it
demonstrates that if Trump will just
stick to the good stuff he could
actually be quite a popular president
you know hurricanes like this boost the
president's popularity they always boost
the popularity of the President of the
United States and power Barack Obama's
popularity was boosted by hurricane
sandy so much he probably won reelection
Donald Trump is doing a good job with
the hurricane I just wish he would get
out of his own way what do I mean when I
say get out of his own way well he was
doing a joint press conference with the
with Finland's president yesterday and
he was asked about the pardon of Joe
Arpaio and here's what he had to say
about it well a lot of people think it
was the right thing to do Jenna and
actually in the middle of a hurricane
even though it was a Friday evening I
assume the ratings would be far higher
than they would be normally you know the
hurricane was just starting and I put it
out that I had pardoned as we call as we
say Sheriff Joe okay so what why are you
saying that that you were doing he's
doing it for the rings I assume the what
are you saying here is that he wasn't
trying to bury this under the hurricane
in the Arpaio pardon under the hurricane
but the way that it comes out he's
talking about using the hurricane as a
way to get attention for his Arpaio
pardon not very good wording by the
president but I'll take it I'll take it
that what he actually meant here is not
that he wanted higher ratings for the
Opera pie a pardon but that he actually
was not doing it to hide the Arpaio
pardons he and then of course does it
the exact wrong way Dana Bash comes down
she says it's important clearly he was
doing it for the ratings
it's clip seven even if he is tongue in
cheek which I don't think he was the
notion of the President of the United
States saying that he announced
something because ratings were high
where people were leading their homes
excuse me fleeing their homes under
water and some people losing their lives
is a port okay again this is overwrought
stuff from the media but Trump has to
know that's the way this is gonna go
again he he just he keeps making some
boo-boos that are not really great he
came out the same day and he was asked
about Russia again once again it's not
difficult for him just to condemn Russia
there was a big story that came out from
the New York Times
it doesn't really hold a lot of water as
far as I can see but the story seems to
suggest
that there was a trump associate who
boasted to another trump associate that
trump had a deal that was pending in
Moscow and because of that deal with
Moscow Vladimir Putin was gonna lend his
support to Trump for the presidency and
get Trump elected it could just be
braggadocio by one of trumps associates
but it would be good if Trump would
condemn Russia every soph and he still
seems to have a tough time doing it here
was Trump being asked about Russia as a
security threat mr. Trump would you
consider Russia as a security threat
thank you well I consider many countries
as a security threat unfortunately when
you look at what's going on in the world
today as you know a few weeks ago our
great Vice President Mike Pence's right
here was in the region and spent quite a
bit of time there we consider that a
very very important part of the world we
have great relationships there we have a
great relationship with Finland and so I
would consider many countries threats
but these are all threats that we'll be
able to handle that we have to hopefully
we won't have to handle them but if we
do we will handle them okay I think you
know when President Trump says there are
many threats he'd be good if you would
just say Russia is a threat obviously
Russia is a threat to Finland Russia
invaded Finland or - so you know him
sort of shying away from that is not a
good move but I wish she would stop this
that we could focus on what he's doing
on the hurricane which so far has been
pretty much misstep free I haven't seen
a lot of boo-boos for president Trump
during this hurricane and his driving
left up a wall okay time for a quick
thing I like a quick thing I hate and
then we'll deconstruct a little bit of
culture so a thing that I like so we're
gonna talk a little bit of philosophy
this week so yesterday I recommended the
story of philosophy which is a book by
Will Durant that came out in 1926 goes
through a lot of the major philosophers
one of the ones he doesn't spend a lot
of time on and who is kind of lost I
would say some of his some of his luster
but was the leading philosopher of the
foundation of the country was John Locke
John Locke second treatise on government
is a masterwork
it is all about why men are deserving of
a government that protects their
individual rights John Locke really is
the the great propagator of the notion
that we have rights in spite of
government and government is instituted
in order to maintain those rights he
exists in opposition to Thomas Hobbes
Hobbes says that men in a state of
nature beat the living crap out of each
other
and you need government in order to
ensure that men don't beat the crap out
of each other so I've got better at
Leviathan right better the the
government Leviathan then the freedom of
nature and Locke says basically
government is also staffed by men and
government can also become tyrannical
it's not a long work the Second Treatise
of government but it is easy it's
actually relatively easy to read for a
philosopher there's some philosophers
that are very difficult to read cons is
very difficult to read it's pretty
abstruse John Locke is actually very
readable so if you want to get your
start on the philosophers that made a
difference in American thought Locke is
a beautiful way to start Second Treatise
of government so check that out okay
time for a thing that I hate so over at
USC there is a horse the horse is the
horse is the mascot okay the horse is
the mascot I know this because Tommy
Trojan always rides the horse in the in
in in the statue in the games
Tommy Trojan rides the horse over at
UCLA we used to prank the horse
sometimes in any case they're a bunch of
leftists who now think that the horse's
name has to be changed because the name
of the horse is traveller okay and the
USC black student assembly co-director
Sofia Jackson thinks that the name of
the horse should be changed why because
robert e lee's horse name was also
traveler okay the actual name of the
horse at USC only has one l robert e
lee's horse had two L's but it doesn't
matter it wasn't named after Robert E
Lee's horse still she says that it must
be changed and now there's campaign
afoot to change Travelers name it's just
absurd it's just absurd Brent Musburger
I think had this exactly right
this is the retired sports announcer he
was asked about changing the name of the
stupid horse that's the stupid mascot
for the stupid USC Trojans and here's
what he had to say about it I'm very
upset with USC yeah what because I did
that I'm very upset okay I mean there's
a there's a move afoot to change the
name of the horse from traveler because
robert e lee's horse was named travis
can't have that okay again just absurd
all the way through but the absurdity is
only growing on these college campuses
today yale announced that it was
removing a decorative piece of stonework
from the mane and
it's Center for teaching and learning
why because there's a picture of a
Puritan pointing a gun at a Native
American so the these they spoke with
faculty and other scholarly experts they
said the stonework depicted violence
toward local Native American inhabitants
so the university decided to relocate
the stonework it had been wrested by the
York Street entrance to the Sterling
Memorial Library but after that entrance
which hadn't been used for a long time
was reopened the head librarian and the
university's Committee on art in public
spaces decided that the carvings
presence at a major entrance to Sterling
was not appropriate instead they're
removing it and they're moving it
elsewhere they've decided to move the
carving and contextualise it
contextualize it
they say the layer covering the original
stonework will be removed as well they
said we have to create a setting that
clearly communicates that the content of
the image is not being honored or even
taken lightly but rather as deserving of
thoughtful consideration and reflection
again
the wiping away of history it turns out
that the Puritans who settled the area
in which Leyla Yale is located actually
did go to war with the Native Americans
on a relatively frequent basis that is
not a call for violence against Native
Americans today and if you think it is
that's because you're dumb but to ignore
the history of the region or move it
into the back room because it's
uncomfortable seems to me completely
counterproductive and stupid but that's
what our college campuses have become ok
time for a little bit of deconstructing
the culture because it is a Tuesday
today we're actually going to up here
deconstructing the culture Katy Perry
has a new song that is typically garbage
delicious called swish swish it is with
who's in this song Nicki Minaj okay so
two of my very favorite people just
spectacular apparently they're a bunch
of Taylor Swift references in the swish
swish music video so she's in some sort
of catfight with Taylor Swift who also
wrote a garbage song targeting Katy
Perry called look what you made me do or
something it's it's it's an awful song
like I gave it a listen just to see how
awful it was and I think that
swish-swish is a better song than then
tie than taylor swift response song but
that's like saying that certain types of
feces are less offensive than other
types of theses in any case here is the
music video for swish-swish replete with
social justice messaging of course
it says bingos bail bond stadiums she's
sitting atop a pyramid of basketballs
looking all weird and then she falls
down the pyramid and the basketball head
a janitor okay so so Katy Perry's
basketball team is going up against
apparently a bunch of wrestlers in this
video what in the world is going on
[Music]
okay this is all confusing and I'm
hesitant to show the rest the video
because it's so randomly confusing okay
Katy Perry is jumping in the air and
trying to get the basketball and she has
it he came down with the basketball and
then it's stolen this is a garbage song
in a garbage music video
what okay I'm sorry I just what in the
world is going on and there's some point
where Nicki Minaj shows up right who was
high when they constructed this thing
okay okay so I'm assuming it is sometime
soon so I can't sit here indefinitely
waiting for Nicki Minaj to show up okay
it's coming okay and there Rob
Gronkowski is in the audience okay
she's sitting on the bench and then
Nicki Minaj is about to show up and
throw a basketball in her I think
[Music]
the worst music video I've ever seen in
my industry life it makes no sense at
all and then Nicki Minaj the actual the
actual lyrics here I'm just gonna read
the lyrics because I don't know when
Nicki Minaj is gonna show up you can
keep showing it without the sound cuz I
can't handle it but apparently so it
says a tiger don't lose no sleep don't
need opinions from a shellfish or a
sheep don't you come for me no not today
your calculated I got your number cuz
you're a joker I'm a courtside killer
Queen and you will kiss the ring you
best believe me so keep calm honey I'm a
stick around for more than a minute get
used to it funny my name keeps coming
out cho mouth cuz I stay winning lay
them up like swish swish bish another
one in this basket can't touch this
another one in the casket okay so
apparently she's very upset with Whitney
does anyone know why they're fighting by
the way why are they fighting other than
they're both obnoxious like I guess
they're fighting because celebrities
have to fight with each other and be
obnoxious but this this kind of culture
finally Nicki Minaj shows up and for the
halftime show and then tells Katy Perry
to get her act together she gives her a
buck up speech and throws a basketball
at her if you wonder why our country's
becoming stupider it's because of this
Katy Perry actually is considered a
political voice on the left she has some
buddies considered a political voice on
the left but what is what are people
fighting about why are people yelling at
each other why are people angry with one
another why these singers are multi
bajillion errors angry with one another
we have no idea but they make music
videos of her about it and we're all
supposed to be in sconce tint culture I
think that there is a god-sized hole in
a lot of people's hearts in the United
States and we're filling it with stupid
culture and the culture is getting ever
stupider because we have to fill that MA
somehow and so we end up with with with
idiotic music videos like this that
don't even make any sense aren't funny
are badly constructed but are about some
sort of minor conflict between a couple
of obnoxious people who are so rich they
never have to come within 3,000 miles of
each other if they don't want to okay
I'm so annoyed by this I can't even
express how annoyed I am by this by this
music video and by Katy Perry as a whole
by her new appearance by all of it like
then the new appearance which is the SJW
Warrior routine and then Nick
Minaj lecturing her from her perch atop
I guess the the recycler perch atop the
Pyramid of power and wonder if this is
female empowerment gang I can tell you
this does not make women look very
empowered it just makes women look
stupid and petty that's what this nest
of this video looks like it says in
there's a whole sexist section of ethics
of the fathers where it says that men
should not talk to women because they
waste your time okay I don't think
that's true but I think that if you
watch this music video this is a bunch
of silly women wasting your time and I
would say the same thing if it started a
bunch of dudes but it doesn't okay so
enough of me ranting about Katy Perry
and the stupidity of this nonsense okay
so we will be back here tomorrow we'll
give you all the latest updates on the
hurricane apparently there's been some
violence breaking out around the
hurricane looters shooting at people
attempting to help people so just as we
were seeing some of the best in Houston
we're also seeing some of the worst
we'll give you the all the updates I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]